BUFFALO MADE STRIDES WINNING 4
OF 5 THEMSELVES IN THEIR FIRST
SEASON UNDERY MISSED THE LINE RS
IN THE WARAT LONG REACH ANG HIM
TAGE THOMPSON IS UPSTAIRS OVER
OF GOOD CHANCES IN THIS GAME,
THIS IS S  SECONDS.
15th TIME ALL SEASON THE
PENGUINS HAVE TRAILED AFTER ONE.
CROSBY TIE JOKIHARJU IS
BACKINBY SAMUELSSON.
NOE IT IS AND
OLOFSSON ABLE TO FORCE IT ENSON.
PUSHED BY HEINEN LOSES
IT AND I THINK OFFTHIS BANKED  .
IT GOES OFF  CENTERMAN FOR YOU
BUT A SHOOT-FIRST GUY, ISN'T?
>> Darren: HE IS SHOOTING AND
SCORING R TEAM'S
BEST HERE.WE HAVE TO CONTINUE T
THESE PLAYERS TO GET BETTER AND
BETTER.
WE WANT THEM TO BE IS AGAINST
THE NEW YORK RANGERS WHAT COULD
BECAREER.
>> Brendan: YEP.
OUT OF THE TIME-OUT.T.MALKIN CH
THE POWER PLDIFFICULHIS SECOND
PITTSBURGH AFTER
HE WANTS TO GET IT BACK TO HIM.
MARINO SHUT IT DOWN.
PERIOD.
MATHESONY CROSBY.
>> Brendan: HIS FIFTH ATTEMPT OF
THE SEASON.
HE IS 1 FOD OF
CHEATING TOWARD HI SABRES.